Speaker 1: Let's go.
We're kind of going around the world a little
bit today.
Let's go to is it sogar from Melbourne, Australia?
Speaker 4: Hey, David, it's Melbourne, Australia,
yes.
OK, so soccer,
Speaker 1: soccer, beautiful, welcome.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
So two quick questions.
Number one, there was a book that came out
recently this week.
It was called the one hundred percent democracy
the case for Universal Voting, as well as
to Washington Op-Ed pieces.
I was just curious because I watched one of
your videos from seven years ago and you seemed
in favor of universal voting.
But you were more you weren't really strong
in your conviction.
I do wonder seven years later and the and
seeing the advent of the Trump administration
and voting suppression.
How do you become stronger in your conviction
for the case for universal voting?
Speaker 1: Now, just to be clear, do you mean
mandatory voting?
Speaker 4: Oh, yes.
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah.
Here's the thing, I'm I'm not I'm not big,
I'm big on everybody voting, but I'm not so
big on mandatory voting.
I respect the idea that opting out of the
of participating is a valid expression of
of politics.
What I disagree with is people who don't vote
because of apathy, people who just don't pay
attention, people who don't care.
So for me, it's not about for everybody to
vote.
And in fact, if you do that, that that might
that could potentially be a disaster.
I'm more about I want to work towards a system
or a framework where everybody wants to vote.
I want people to want to vote rather than
to force people to vote.
Does that make sense?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I completely understand because
I was also of a similar opinion because I'm
originally from Canada and I moved to Australia
about eight years ago, so I was with you on
the whole, like I want to just make it as
easy as possible for people to vote.
But the thing I noticed because Australia
does have mandatory voting, and as now as
a citizen, I see that there's a very strong
case for it because, ah, first of all, the
elections here are held on Saturdays, so it's
pretty easy to vote already.
And so really, the only thing that could come
in hand is voter apathy and my very strong
belief.
I believe voter apathy is corrosive to democracy.
Agree is extreme.
It's a democracy as well as the election days
here, an event.
So if you had to a polling booth, you're going
to have a sausage, you're going to have drinks.
It's going to be you're going to have time
to to talk with our representatives from the
from the from the parties.
Sure.
And it becomes this cherished institution.
And I do believe and also in addition to the
whole mandatory thing, it's a fifty dollar
fine here.
And for the most part, two thirds of those
fines get waived.
And so for the most part, there isn't much
of a penalty, but it's just it's just this
thing that has become ingrained in Australian
society voting.
And it's and when you look at the results,
it's 96 percent turnout.
Ninety five percent turnout, very high turnout.
And it's really and again, in my very strong
opinion, if you want to maintain a democracy,
voting needs to be a civil duty similar to
how taxes is paying your taxes as a civil
duty.
I believe that voting should be just as strong.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, you've made a very strong case for it,
and I'm willing to listen to arguments in
that direction.
Thank you for the for the phone call.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much.
David Cohen.
Speaker 1: This one very powerful call, I
must say, extremely well prepared.
That's really the that is actually the call
everybody should aspire to.
Couple of minutes long, polite, good audio
right to the topic.
Prepared.
Beautiful.
Beautifully done.
Let's go next to Spencer from California.
Spencer, go.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, thanks for taking my
call.
So.
I think one thing that we encourage is, or
at least you encourage on your show is teaching
media literacy and viewing it as something
that has a positive impact on in terms of
educating people.
Yes, I was reading an article which says that
part of the way we teach media literacy is
telling readers to critically think about
how information is constructed.
Who's paying for it and what's being left
out.
And as a result, this leads to some level
of distrust and maybe even hostility towards
new forces the way that we learn it, and maybe
this even drives some ethical ization.
So what's the right way to develop media literacy
skills while trying to prevent this effect
of causing people to have this predisposition
that media is not to be trusted?
Speaker 1: You know, I thought that the caller
before you was one of the best calls we've
had.
This may be in contention for one of the best
calls.
This is a perfectly constructed question,
so your question is a brilliant one, which
is if one has not been exposed to.
The basic skepticism that we should bring
to any messages we receive, and this means
a sign on the outside of a building, a TV
commercial, a news report.
If your first exposure to this type of critical
thinking is in media literacy, you might incorrectly
develop a hostility towards media because
you've never thought about this framework
before.
And all of a sudden you're being told we've
got to apply it specifically to media.
You're 100 percent right.
And so what we need to do is that framework
of how to think about things, how to know
why we believe the things we believe it has
to be introduced earlier before the context
is even media literacy.
And here's what I mean.
If two years before media literacy becomes
a topic, you are generally instructed on how
to evaluate whether something should be believed
or not.
And it's applied to everything.
It's applied to the things your classmates
say.
It's applied to all sorts of phenomena.
Why?
Why do you believe?
How do you know what your age is?
How old or how old are we kids were seven.
How do you know that?
Do you remember each of the seven years?
Well, no.
It's because our parents told us, OK.
And how do you right?
So if you first develop that as a general
framework for evaluating why we believe the
things we believe once it's applied to media,
it shouldn't generate that sort of distrust
and you're 100 percent correct.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think that makes a lot
of sense.
And then one more question.
Speaker 1: Sure, it's going to be I mean,
you know, you may want to go out on top, but
but let's see.
I don't know if the next question could possibly
live up to the first one there.
Speaker 5: So maybe on a sort of related issue,
how do you respond to friends and people who
are simply misinformed, but they're not too
far removed from reality in their beliefs?
So, for instance, maybe someone who thinks
that Biden is largely responsible for gas
prices, they might have just heard that somewhere
and blindly repeated it.
Yeah, without checking for themselves.
And in essence, what I'm asking is, what's
the best way to confront these people and
tell them that they're wrong without seeming
too argumentative or just flat out telling
them that they're incorrect?
Speaker 1: Oh, I mean, that one's very easy,
particularly if it's people you generally
get along with.
You would say, Oh yeah, it's interesting.
Biden's responsible for the high gas prices.
Tell me more about that.
What?
What did Biden do to raise gas prices?
And almost certainly they're already going
to go nowhere.
And then I would say, Oh well, because, you
know, gas prices are up in every country.
Does Biden affect gas prices in every country?
And if so, how?
I mean, I would just diffuse that with some
very light questions.
Speaker 5: Right.
Yeah.
I was thinking that was the approach to go.
Speaker 1: All right.
Excellent phone call.
I congratulate you.
Thanks for taking my call.
All right, very good, guys.
I'm almost scared to take the next call because
it's going to be very hard to live up to some
of these